let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 and see what is on people's
minds starting today with our caller
from the 2:04 area code caller from 2:04
what's your name where are you calling
from
hi David my name is Trevor I'm calling
from Winnipeg Manitoba up in Canada hey
how's it going today I'm doing pretty
good I just want to pick your brain here
I was wondering why is it that Trump
doesn't seem to attack Bernie as much as
everybody else it seems you know there's
so much you know he's talked about Biden
and and a little bit worn and and just
but it just seems like he doesn't he
doesn't push the the Bernie thing as
much as a as much as I everybody else do
you find that - I do find that I do
think that he has this crazy Bernie
nickname and he's been tweeting about
that I I think there's a couple
possibilities here one is he genuinely
doesn't think Bernie's going to be the
nominee so he feels it's a waste of time
to talk about Bernie the other
possibility is he's actually scared of
having to go against Bernie in a way
that he's not scared of some of the
others although it's mere speculation I
know that there's lots of hardcore
Bernie or Buster's who say bernie is the
only guy that could beat Trump so Trump
is only afraid of Bernie I've not seen
any evidence of that but it is possible
that there's something about Bernie that
makes Trump hesitant to attack him
because of what he thinks might happen
if Bernie is indeed the nominee but your
guess is as good as mine yeah I think
yeah I kind of agree with you that he I
feel that the only reason he hasn't
really gone after him is is he's kind of
scared of him you know that's the only
kind of thing I could probably think of
you know the only thing is it doesn't
really match Trump's personality Trump
in general is not really scared of
people other than people who seem to
kind of have him over a barrel right
whether it's people who he owes money to
or people bailing him out financially or
whatever the catered on him I don't know
that Bernie falls into those categories
so it's it would be unlike Trump but
again we're just kind of speculating
here
my guess is if it seems clearer after a
couple of primaries that bernie is a
real contender and starts to accumulate
some delegates my guess is you'll see
Trump start to attack him more yeah -
like that like yeah yeah exactly like he
doesn't seem to be scared of anybody so
that's why I was so kind of perplexed
why he wouldn't be full-on attacking him
as much as everybody else yeah I mean
three we have may be having a different
conversation depending on what happens
Trevor thank you for the call yeah
thanks I appreciate your show okay
all right great to hear from you